-Our next guest is
an Emmy-nominated actress
and writer you know from
her work in "The Big Sick,"
"The Plot Against America,"
and "Olive Kitteridge."
She stars in "She Said," which
is in theaters November 18th.
Let's take a look.
-What is it exactly
that we're looking at here?
-We're looking at extreme sexual
harassment in the workplace.
These young women walked into
what they all had reason to
believe were business meetings
with a producer, an employer.
They were hopeful.
They were expecting
a serious conversation
about their work
or a possible project.
Instead, they say he met them
with threats and sexual demands.
They claim assault and rape.
If that can happen
to Hollywood actresses,
who else is it happening to?
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Zoe Kazan, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back!
-Thank you.
-Congratulations on the movie.
But more importantly,
congratulations.
You and your partner, Paul Dano,
had another baby four weeks ago.
-We did.
-You look amazing.
-Thank you.
-You seem amazing.
I don't know
if this is all a facade,
but you overall look
like you're doing okay.
-Thank you.
About five minutes ago,
I was in your dressing room
with, like, breast pumps in.
So, uh, I feel great.
-Okay, good.
I know you have
a 4-year-old, as well.
Accepting to the new sibling
so far?
-She's very, very sweet to him.
And she's, like, really
expressing her emotions to me.
-Oh, interesting.
So anything -- any problem
she has with it,
she's bringing to you,
as opposed to taking it out --
-Yeah, which is fair, 'cause
he's 4 weeks old and I'm 39.
-Yeah, yeah, you're probably --
If she's judging who's the best
one to bring the complaints to,
very sharp kid.
So this movie
obviously is based on
an incredible piece of reporting
both that Megan and Jodi did
and then their book "She Said."
You had obviously read the book.
What was it like the first time
you got together --
you and Carey got together
with the people you're playing?
-Yeah, so Carey and I have been
friends for 14 years.
So, like, we were going
into this together.
And we were incredibly nervous.
We had, like, a four-way Zoom
because this was, like,
I don't know,
the spring of 2021.
And we, like,
all popped on together
and we're like, "Surprise!
Like, this is your life.
We're going to be you."
Um, I was really intimidated.
They're, like, Pulitzer
Prize-winning journalists.
But they were so nice
and so generous with us
and, like, let me ask
all the nosy questions
that I secretly
want to ask everyone.
-That's great
that you got to do that.
It also was surreal, I heard,
because you were shooting
in Brooklyn.
They live in Brooklyn.
So you actually ran --
like, they ran into you
while you were on set
playing them.
-Yeah, like,
Jodi literally ran into us.
She was out for a run
in Prospect Park,
and we were, like,
shooting in Prospect Park.
And she texted me, being like,
"This is gonna sound weird,
but are you shooting
in my neighborhood?"
And I had to be like,
"Yes, come on in!"
So we have, like, you know,
sweaty selfies on set.
-What did you learn about
by doing this
the way stories like this
are reported
that you maybe didn't know?
-Yeah, I mean, okay, so I had a
kind of, like, I think,
naive vision that, like,
an investigative reporter
would, like, seek out the truth,
learn the truth,
and then, like, publish it
in a newspaper.
Turns out it's a lot more
complicated than that.
Like, they just needed, like,
verification for everything,
like, three sources
for everything.
I think, like, I had to,
like, dismantle my, like,
LEGO version of being
a "New York Times" reporter.
Yeah.
-One of the things that was --
I mean, the worst
possible reason
for "The New York Times"
building to be open
for you to shoot there
is there was a pandemic
and none of the reporters
were there.
But you did get to shoot in
the "New York Times" building.
-Yeah, we're the first
narrative film
to shoot in
the "New York Times" building,
and the reason is because
no one was allowed
to be inside of there.
Jodi and Megan hadn't been there
for like 18 months
when we were shooting in there.
So it was a little bit like
being in a building
where everyone
had been raptured.
Like, there was, like, you know,
Valentine's Day candy
on people's desks
and, like, their heels
under the desk
and, like, you know,
memos that were dated,
like, March 9, 2020.
-Yeah, that say, like,
"Call me. It's important."
-Yeah, ASAP.
"Something's happening
in China." Yeah.
-You mentioned you met Carey
14 years ago.
Was that professionally?
Did you guys work?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, we were in a play
on Broadway together.
And we shared a dressing room
about the size of your desk.
-So, I'm so glad you --
I feel like this is
the great unknown thing
when people go
to Broadway shows.
'Cause they're so grand
and palatial rooms.
But I'm always blown away by
how tiny the dressing rooms are.
-Yeah, I mean, literally
we had, like, our desk --
Our, like, desk where we put on
our makeup was this big.
And we would put our, like,
sleeping bags underneath it
and snuggle up together and both
take a nap between shows
under truly about this size.
So, you know, like,
if we didn't become friends,
we definitely were going to
become enemies
in that situation.
-Well, it's certainly --
it's certainly nice
that it worked out this way.
-Yeah.
-And it must be also nice,
obviously,
telling a story like this
that has been, you know,
both told in the press
and told via book form --
it's great to do it
as a film, as well.
And are Megan and Jodi --
are they happy with how
you've gone about doing it?
-I mean, if they aren't happy,
they're really acting happy.
They're doing a great job
convincing us.
No, no, no,
they're being so kind.
And we've all been
so concerned about --
You know, this is a very
delicate subject matter.
And I think that there's stuff
about the film
that's really entertaining,
but at the end of the day,
it's also, you know,
very, very heavy
and sensitive subject matter.
So my eye has been
so much on, like,
are all these survivors happy
or do they feel okay
about their representation,
that I kind of forgot
about Jodi and Megan.
Then I saw them at the premiere
and was like, "Hey!
Hope you think
I did a good job!"
-I'm sure they did.
It is always so nice to see you.
Thank you so much
for being with us, Zoe.
-Thanks for having me.
Thank you.
-Zoe Kazan, everybody!
"She Says" is in theaters
November 18th.
We'll be right back with music
from Paolo Nutini.